citation needed join me today he reads
books you know it's Chris Joel Oh Gary
Ellen and the bouncy smell and the
internet Matt gray the other new YouTube
in front of me I've got an article from
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fight we get right is a point and
a ding and the special price for
particular good answers which is talking
about atomic Annie oh is it a terrible
way to teach people how to do
resuscitation
now children after the bombs fall you
may find that the person you're
resuscitating has bad breath it's not
the topic
rasuu cyanne no it's not
he's a real person who we see on the
other the thing you use when you're
doing
resuscitation practice the folks see
what doesn't say oh I recognize you from
well oh let us cast our minds back to
Athens I think it's no it must be 19th
century Paris or early 20th century
Paris whatever who knows okay click when
you pressed adjust what were they doing
I you know a dead body pull out the same
right no no no see an is based on an
unidentified corpse that was pulled out
of the Seine and they cast the face and
the person this is where it gets grim
the person who did the art something
like the curtain or that was a bucket
they pulled the body on whoever was
doing the autopsy thought she was so
beautiful he made a cast of her face and
that is the face that is used on the
wrist will see on dolls I'm not giving
you any point it's not even remotely
related to the subject
you are entirely wrong by a process of
elimination we know what it isn't though
a shell
it's like someone came along now that's
a fit corpse yeah my god will you put it
that way yeah yeah suits the question of
the clicking noise yeah you are
absolutely right a young woman whose
death mask became a fixture on the walls
of artists homes yeah don't do that is
it in the testing sites is it the fridge
that indium Jones Maninder that's atomic
smog which it is certainly military
hardware but you're not close enough to
to get a point here is it when they
tried to power a plane with a nuclear
reactor in the 50s Oh No what realize
that I haven't got I'm it was when when
that were an atomic power was the way of
the future harm no one did you not see
what we just did guys anyone yeah they
were building sort of nuclear reactors
down to I presume like the size of this
stage and they put one in a must have
been a b-29 oh you brought 36 sorry it
must have been a b-36 cut that anyway
they made a nuclear-powered airplane and
I don't think it worked was they stopped
doing it a man if he's out of
Thunderbirds they never actually
connected the engines to the propeller
now that's where they went right it's
not going in yeah there's some dude is
still in the middle penguin huh no
metric and imperial has one thing that
too much science fiction has taught me
it's that going like that immediate
result some Lotus sparks you have taken
off no blondy album it's an atomic
something it's ground-based
ordnance here cannon point our ordnance
cannon Bouchet
a topic trebuchet are you finally Thomas
just a massive atomic power it's an
atomic power thing because it's gonna
fire outs with you and make a hole again
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
an atomic cannon developed her developed
about 150 Tuesday Wednesday in the 50s
yes at a point our early nineteen
fifties and even at the point there um
at the beginning of the Cold War
well of course it was fifties if it's
atomic they develop for three years the
idea being to make a cannon that would
fire a small nuclear device that's
ballsy how'd they get around having rain
how big was this very same very big and
quicker to treads bigger yeah I'm giving
you a point for big I'll give you a
point for two it was two tractors but
yet required two extra long fire trucks
to move the thing okay it is an eighty
four ton gun did it need to be that big
yes
if you fire atomic weapons you want it
far enough away that the blast wave
doesn't get you which means it needs to
be a big as previously mentioned what
about what was its effective firing
range far somewhere in three digits of
miles Price is Right rules six miles
I haven't specified it will say 200
miles price is right go six miles a
furlong might have been a failure it
came out the top which went
which is not great for an atomic device
but no about 20 miles and they did
actually fire this
where did they fire this in the desert
I'll give you the point for desert the
Nevada Test Site yeah the one yeah you
can still go to the weirdly on a
day-trip bit far going by nuclear cannon
obviously did Park ever right in atomic
cannon did what the test was successful
yeah hey they made 20 of the cannons
they cost Lindsay what were they
planning on doing in the 50s with 20
cannon oh I'm shooting the Russians
remember miles away how big is the lung
gap between the US and Russia drive into
an empty bit of Alaska and shale and
empty in victory you invented there gary
is a really bad intercontinental
ballistic missile well this isn't it yes
um but it wasn't just Europe and Russia
it was deployed to where else would they
have sent it to did they send it to
Korea - she beats him oh yes they did
and what were some of the problems with
this didn't work that did work it got
all leaves in it everything that was
carrying it went backwards faster than
the thing went forwards when they got
there it wasn't really all that useful
why not because the Russians did invent
an atomic super cannon
yes it's called an intercontinental
ballistic as we as we scientists call it
yes you're absolutely right the better
things had been invented so while they
still had it it was still a prestige
weapon they didn't ever actually fire it
in the end they realized I could just
make atomic shells for what beaches any
artillery piece in the inventory exactly
right they didn't need the cannon they
could just build a bigger regular cannon
and put a nuclear shell in it
um there was something else here called
the Davy Crockett weapon system this
wasn't attempt with a nuclear device in
another bit of weaponry what might this
have been a firework
we're not back to wedging things in caps
owing Assad dragged me closer
hit them with my nucleus or you perch it
on the end like the Davy Crockett musket
burn lets you know what your clothes it
was a recoilless rifle ah so essentially
a rocket launcher
with a nuclear bomb on the end and it
didn't have any recoil that recoilless
rifle essentially means the back end is
open so you better base is putting a
hollow tube up and the exhaust gases
come out about hollow tube ER they're
all hollow do you want to do the gesture
we've all done it once come on what are
some of the problems with this with it
with a right shoulder mounted rocket
launcher you want to carry the
ammunition and it's right next to your
head that didn't have the range to get
you out of blast distance and that's the
big one yes so this is fine yeah yeah
it's fine it's glowing you know that day
yeah yeah it's all cool if this hits
that guy am i dead as well yeah
just drop it in fact in fact just drop
it he dies instantly you get a slow
lingering death that's the other problem
instantly lethal within 150 meters of
where a hit fatal dose with a quarter
mile of landing just drop it just
legging it also what what couldn't you
do to the bomb after you fired it pick
it up
hug it use it again I hate to watercolor
I said fired not wondered it's not like
you gotta bought it it explodes with
them a nuclear bomb if it's gonna get
you anyway it's gonna get you sooner if
you're both so it wasn't an abort option
no it's a nuclear bomb
you've already fired it well that's no
what sets off a nuclear bomb yeah that's
true yeah you're fired you fire it or
you drop it or whatever and then the
time it sets it off because nuclear
bombs have accidentally fallen out
haven't they gone off they even exploded
because there's one in this one off the
coast of Spain or something like that oh
don't look up list of nuclear accidents
on Wikipedia Terrace
there's certainly one off the waters if
I think it's Georgia in the US so but
you don't want to turn the timer off
because then you've given it to them and
they're just gonna throw it back to you
Oh hmm say in the post
well you just set the timer you address
it in a big box that looks like a
birthday cake you put it away you have a
box that looks like a birthday cake
because that box it looks like a
birthday cake is in a bigger box it
looks like the kind of box of birthday
cake make boxing so you a spy and you
haven't told us all right and then you
address it to head of FBI the Pentagon
happy birthday and then like your mom
always does on birthday cards do not
open until and he'll go well for my
birthday it's in a few weeks
puts it in the coroner's office opens up
a cake cut into the cake and that's when
your timer goes off oh don't you get it
so then the bomb pops out of the cake
and goes happy birthday
[Applause]
[Applause]
that was you bowling it straight down
the middle of the crease it well crease
meanwhile in Britain there is a somewhat
related slightly ridiculous weapon as
opposed to where we've been perfectly
sensible to now and it's called blue
peacock this was a British attempt to
create a tactical nuclear weapon they
were gonna put nuclear mines in Germany
what's the problem with burying
something like that that is that is one
problem yes one problem with that is
that during the winter it gets very cold
the electronics don't work how do you
keep something like that underground
warm what was the plan thermos flask
sending sheep outs of we on it
I'm never going camping with you they
did they song used to last a week or so
so how do you keep that warm from we oil
fire blankets no it's something that's
gonna generate its own heat for a while
a cat you are very close cows a bit big
to bury their with they buried animals
with the things that one was to bury a
chicken so I'm gonna give you the point
how goes okay we've got this bomb this
high-tech nuclear thing yeah we need and
what we need to do is we put it
underground and we need to keep it warm
what does it mean to protected Jeff Jeff
we can come up with the better so
chicken are we talking a box here with a
live chicken in it and an egg sized
nuclear weapon so that the chicken just
gives it this number until the timer
goes off that sounds like it at work
yeah actually that was but that was the
plan it never actually happened isn't a
motion detection bomb and you putting a
chicken one of the floppiest animals of
no no no it doesn't detect itself so how
do you set up these battle you set off
these markets it you sit right so you
make your box you put your chicken you
bug the chickens in the mine
yes yeah pressure pad on top or right
it's really really high-tech I think and
then you put a chicken inside does that
Scott what's gonna make this hotel thing
better working temperature without
needing to plug anything into it or keep
it running I sometimes have problems
starting my car in the winter shall I
put a chicken in the end you know just
taking the cold this or sweet treats of
that away right your your even signpost
it's a minefield would you like today
you approach this mysteriously newly dug
field that has nothing on it apart from
the sound of cooking well I see it works
don't believe it because you wouldn't
follow over that feeling what is it
field of ghost chicken well the chickens
suspect his way out and suddenly from
beneath the soil chicken's head just
pops out the right wing radio chicken
stuff popping out of the ground all over
and that's before the bombs gone off
second proposed second atom bill can I
just say suddenly irradiated chicken is
the name of my new problem
I like your the cluck from below like
it's a horror film new from M night sure
what awadhi the clock from below many
animals were harmed in the making so at
the end of the show congratulations Matt
this week yeah
our congratulations you win a rope that
keeps out vultures owned by the star of
Gavin & Stacey in The Late Late Show its
James Corden's Condor Corden so do enjoy
that
[Music]
you